the Joe Rogan experience dude I'm
terrified of the ocean why getting in
that water with all those from anybody
other than you yeah but most of them
don't care about you all most of them
you just knock it out um keyword and
yeah yeah most yeah I did I went to the
Galapagos over this year and I did saw
hammerhead sharks while snorkeling was
nothing cuter than a baby hammerhead
like this big really amazing like a
footlong it was a cutest thing ever
but like yeah I can see how the ocean is
big and dark and scary dude it's
terrifying yeah I know I guess I still
get a little nervous when I go in the
ocean you should be monsters in there
you know I know this is what I always
say about sharks if there was a werewolf
and the werewolf came out every full
moon yeah every full moon if you were
outside your house you got murdered you
just got ripped apart it happened to one
person every full moon all across the
land yeah
people would be like [ __ ] man I'm not
going out on a full moon okay sharks are
like werewolves but they're werewolves
every day of the year
I don't think shark attacks are that
comment because they don't they don't
see you and you're not supposed to be
there so they're not accustomed to you
if they were accustomed to you like if
we lived in the water with sharks do you
think the moral community that sharks
have to be good neighbors who keep them
from eating us if we were like just
everywhere in the water all the time as
sharks figured it out they'll be like oh
we could just eat them eat them they
just just just dumb they don't know
they're supposed to eat us they have a
look narrow thing in their eye of what
they're supposed to be yeah they don't I
don't think they like us I don't think
they want to eat us they're just not
accustomed to it you know their their
focus is slip don't when they bite
people don't they spit them out a lot
they rarely finish a human you see them
they take a limb they don't finish a
human I saw jaws dude in Johnson finish
people and it was also like [ __ ]
license plates and [ __ ] remember oh yeah
they eat trash yeah yeah your [ __ ] to
eat everything
yeah but they probably wouldn't eat to
license plates in a row I don't think
they think I think it's just eating
machines there's no I don't
Catalina way better but I don't think
there's any evidence that sharks are
like wizards
more clever like dolphins are clever as
[ __ ] orcas are glad we know sharks just
cease murders just with a continual roll
of teeth yeah the teeth fall out new one
pops in bang like a rotor but I don't go
diving where there's [ __ ] date
[Applause]
neighborhood they can just decide to go
to your neighborhood it's like if you
were if you were camping [ __ ] up anyway
and out there in that campground wolves
were tearing open [ __ ] tents and
pulling people out eating them alive
would you feel like well they never come
up here stay there literally shoving
that shark there feeding that shark to
editage it's a real thing dude they
brought in a werewolf this is what I'm
saying
doesn't matter look if you had a [ __ ]
cage and it could put you in the middle
of the woods and your friend ties a lamb
to the outside of the cage so you can
see the werewolf in real life and it
looks like American well in London
that's that I know that's no [ __ ]
shark-diving what do you want from me
stay on the ocean please do me a favor I
like the ocean look at those teeth I
know I'm so scared for you you know I go
what about Joe don't you go walk what
about mountain lions you can walk I'm
trying to pretend that I'd be able to
stab some mountain lion and get it off I
mean I die for the knife my dog would
try to make friends at the mountain lion
he's so nice you know what he barks at
hilarious the only thing you barks at is
well the bark said when people have a
Santa Claus on the driveway what the
[ __ ] is that normal thing for him to say
glowing so we're walking and I take him
to the trail and I open up the back to
let him out he jumps out onto the
sidewalk it looks at this guys [ __ ]
this guy's fake snowman it starts
barking oh my oh my god just some
[ __ ] thing yeah it's not really a
person and then he just runs up the hill
[Applause]